22 de marzo de 2016 aeropuerto de
Bruselas dojiihadistas se inmolan en la
sala de embarque a las 8 de la mañana
una tercera explosión suena una hora
después en una estación de metro del
barrio europeo estos atentados
reivindicados por el estado islámico
dejaron 32 muertos y más de 300 heridos
Los investigadores pronto se dieron
cuenta de que estos atentados habían
sido preparados por la misma célula
Franco huelga que había golpeado París y
el 13 de noviembre de 2015 los atentados
de Bruselas se produjeron cuatro días
después de la detención de salah de slam
El único miembro sobreviviente de este
Comando seis años después en la capital
belga un Jurado de 36 personas sorteadas
es el encargado de juzgar a los acusados
nuevos hombres deben comparecer seis de
ellos ya han sido juzgados en el juicio
de los atentados del 13 de noviembre
entre ellos alab de slam y mohamedbrini
ocho enfrentan cadena perpetua por
asesinato y tentativa de asesinato
terroristas por el lado de las partes
civiles más de mil personas reclaman
indemnizaciones por daños y perjuicios
los familiares de los 32 asesinados y
los heridos traumatizados durante las
explosiones la apertura del proceso es
especialmente esperada por estas
víctimas el juicio que se espera
finalice en junio promete ser el mayor
jamás celebrado en Bélgica